estos grupos de personas que están a mis
espaldas en este parque frente al
parlamento iraquí A las afueras de la
zona verde de Bagdad representan una de
las grandes complejidades que tiene Irak
20 años después especialmente en el
sistema político y en esa estructura de
división de partidos políticos que se
creó después de esas primeras elecciones
en el 2005 desde entonces la ley
electoral se ha ido cambiando
paulatinamente y sistemáticamente cada
cuatro años y muchas de estas personas
que están aquí dicen representar al
movimiento de protestas del 2019 que
pedían eso uno de sus puntos era la
reforma de ese sistema electoral En
aquel momento lograron algún cambio
hasta Entonces hasta el 2019 lo que
hacía era que el país estaba dividido en
18 distritos y se votaba por listas
cerradas es la reforma que vino
posteriormente dividió el país en tres
distritos y podían votar por el
candidato de su elección pues el
parlamento que está de regreso
actualmente especialmente después de que
se retirara la agrupación de mutadas El
Líder político que ganó las últimas
elecciones y que retiró a todos sus
representantes hace ya varios meses del
parlamento quieren volver a reformar
para llegar al mismo sistema político de
antes de las elecciones lo que es no es
inadmisible es inadmisible para estos
personas que están aquí que perdieron
más o menos 800 personas en las
protestas del 2019 la sensibilidad de
eso que está sucediendo Se te va
reflejado en la cantidad de policías
antimotines que hay en los alrededores
hoy Bagdad es una ciudad totalmente
militarizada impidiendo de que vuelvan a
surgir protestas como las del 2019 Pero
también es interesante rescatar que
estas protestas están apoyadas no
solamente por el movimiento sader sino
también por los líderes religiosos de
nayafe especialmente por el ayatola
Alice hispánica es la máxima autoridad
del país pero también por esos políticos
independientes que tuvieron una buena
participación en las elecciones pasadas
y que van a volver a quedar marginados
con este nuevo sistema electoral